Hi. Welcome back.
In the last session, we looked at how
difficult it is for active investors to
beat the market. Most mutual funds don't
do it. Most individual investors don't
do it. In fact, they spend time and
resources and often end up earning 1%, 1
and 1/2%, 2% less than what they'd have
made with no effort at all. So, in this
session, I want to focus on what happens
if you go down the passive investing
route. We decide that you're not going
to go out and do active investing.
If you make this decision to be a
passive investor, the first thing to do
is not beat yourself up. Many people
view this as giving up. You're not.
You're accepting a reality that winning
at active investing is difficult to do
and maybe it's not your thing to try.
So, the choices on passive investing
boil down to three. First is a classic
index fund.
The very first index fund was created by
by Vanguard in the 1970s, Jack Bogle.
Essentially replicating the S&P 500.
Since then, the index fund business has
exploded. There are hundreds of index
funds indexing pretty much every single
index you can think of. Small caps,
large caps, by geography.
So, we'll start with classic index
funds. What they do, how they construct
it. Then we'll move on to what I call
enhanced index funds.
Along the way, we'll stop and talk about
exchange-traded funds, which have
increasingly over the last two decades
become alternatives to classic index
funds for many investors.
So, let's start with a classic index
fund.
A classic index fund, if it's fully
indexed, is a very simple creation.
Here's what you do.
You first start by by looking at the
index you want to replicate. Let's take
an example. Let's assume you want to
replicate the S&P 500, the most followed
and tracked index in the world.
The second choice you have to make is
what you're going to weight your index
fund on.
Most index funds, if they're constructed
according to at least basic theory, are
index based on market cap. So, you're
going to collect the market
capitalization of every one of the S&P
500 companies.
But, there are alternatives. You could
create an index fund weighted based on
revenues. Large revenue companies are
weighted more. We can have an index fund
that's not weighted at all. It's an
equally weighted index fund.
The market cap weighted index fund is
the most common, but the alternatives
exist. Third, you created a weighted
portfolio of the stocks in the index.
So, basically, you take the 500 stocks
in the S&P 500 and hold them in
proportion to the market cap given how
how big your fund is. That's a fully
index fund.
Now, fully index funds, obviously, are
the right way to go if you truly want to
be just like the index.
But, sometimes creating a fully index
fund might be practically expensive or
very difficult to do.
Let's see why.
Let's suppose you want to create a
global index fund.
You want to hold every traded stock in
the world in proportion to its market
value. It's going to be tough to do,
right? That's 46,000 companies. There,
what you might instead get is a sampled
index fund. What's a sampled index fund?
Instead of getting all large cap stocks,
you might take 20% of the large cap
stocks. Essentially, sample each
grouping based upon its place in the
overall index.
What you will get with a sampled index
fund is something that moves very much
like the index. The statistics work in
your favor. So, even if you own only
4,000 global stocks and there are 46,000
out there, if you created the sampling
right, that 4,000 stock index fund
should move very much with the overall
index.
But there will be gaps. So that's index
funds have been around a long time as I
said from the 1970s.
And we go to a site like Vanguard, the
leading index fund company in the world,
you can pretty much index whatever you
want. If you want an exposure to small
cap stocks, you can find an index of
just small cap stocks. If you want to
replicate a value fund, you can
replicate
a value portfolio of low price to book
stocks, you can find a value fund.
Essentially index funds can capture
whatever you're trying to do.
And over the last few decades, index
funds have increased their share of the
overall market. We talked about why the
last session. It's because active money
managers have underperformed the market
and eventually people investing with
those active money managers decide that
this is not worth it to pay somebody to
lose money for you, and they move their
money to index funds.
As a percentage of total money invested,
index funds have increased from 3.7% in
to 14.2% in 2010 to almost 24% in 2024.
Along the way, as I said, the number of
index funds has exploded.
But the the other way to passively
invest is exchange-traded funds. We'll
talk about that next, but
exchange-traded funds have exploded even
more. They've gone from almost nothing
in 1993
to almost 44% in 2024.
Combining index funds and ETFs together
as passive investing, passive investing
now accounts
basically there for almost 68%
or 67 to 68% of all money invested.
If this were a battle, passive investing
is clearly winning.
So that's traditional index funds. So
let's talk about alternatives to
traditional index funds. I've mentioned
exchange-traded funds. I'll talk about
what ETFs are and why some people might
choose them over an index fund.
You could use index futures and options
and effectively leverage your bets on
the index. Basically, you're still
playing a passive investing game, but
using futures and options.
There are enhanced index funds.
What these try to do is have their cake
and eat it, too. So, they're an index
fund, so they have the low costs, you're
not selecting stocks too much,
but you take a subset of the index. Why
that subset? Because you think it's
going to outperform the index. That's
what I mean by having your cake and
eating eating it, too. You're going the
passive investing route, but you're
still trying to get that extra return
from being an active investor.
Let's talk a little bit about
exchange-traded funds. With
exchange-traded funds, you get many of
the benefits of investing in index fund,
but you get the added liquidity.
Now, where does that additional
liquidity come from?
Unlike an index fund, which is marketed
by a Vanguard or a State Street, you got
to go through that entity to get rid of
what you own or to add more.
With an exchange-traded fund, which is
listed in the market, you can actually
buy and sell at the current price. So,
if that is something you value, you
might use an exchange-traded fund over
an index fund.
Now, when we talked about market timing,
we talked about how people can use index
funds to time the market. If you're
truly timing the market, you might need
that additional liquidity and need it
quickly, so you might go with an
exchange-traded fund instead.
The costs of exchange-traded funds are
slightly higher than index funds,
especially if you're a long-term passive
investor. So, you're asking, "Should I
go with an index fund or an
exchange-traded fund, assuming that both
are offered?"
If you're a long-term passive investor,
you're investing in index funds because
you want to keep your costs low and you
have no desire to time the market or
pick stocks, index funds will work
better for you. If you're investing in
index funds because you still want to
time the market in the background. Get
in and out of markets, you might prefer
an exchange-traded fund.
The final choice is enhanced index
funds. There are three ways in which you
can bypass traditional index funds. The
first is you can use derivatives,
futures, options, swaps to create what
looks just like the index by combining
a derivative with some kind of borrowing
or lending. If I sound mysterious, go
back and review what we talked about in
the context of arbitrage. We talked
about how you can create a replicating
portfolio using call option and
borrowing.
Essentially with a synthetic enhancement
strategy using derivatives plus
something to make to create something
that looks like an index. You're saying,
"Why would I go to that trouble?" Maybe
you can replicate the index
and earn a slightly higher return
because something is being mispriced.
So already you can see a theme emerging
with an enhanced index fund. You want
the benefits of being passive plus an
extra bonus, an additional return.
The second way you can create an
enhanced index fund is a little
trickier.
Basically, you take an index and rather
than weighted based on market cap and
buy every single stock in the index, you
might leave out a few stocks. Why?
Because you don't think they're good
stocks. Already you can see with an
investment-based enhanced indexing
strategy, you're bringing in an active
investing component. You believe small
caps are going to outperform large caps.
So what do you do? You tilt your index
towards small cap companies. You believe
low price-earnings ratio stocks are
better than high price-earnings ratio
stocks in the long term. You tilt your
index towards the low PE stocks. You can
do that either by taking the high PE
stocks out of the index or as is more
commonly done, altering the weight so
low PE stocks are weighted more.
So you're trying to get the benefits of
indexing plus the additional returns
from being an active investor. And
finally, in quantitative enhanced
indexing, what you do is you take an
index and rather than weight based on
market cap, you draw on portfolio
theory. In portfolio theory, there is
this version of maximizing returns for a
given level of risk using optimization
techniques. It's called a Markowitz
portfolio. Basically, you can do the
same thing. You can take an index, you
can compute the expected returns and
standard deviations of every stock and
create some kind of optimization
approach that gives you the index but
better weights on the index. The weight
The weights that supposedly would
deliver better returns or higher returns
in the future. But again, to emphasize
with enhanced index funds, you're trying
to get the benefits of passive
investing, low cost, not too much
activity,
plus additional returns because you're
picking individual stocks.
It's worth noting, though,
that many so-called active funds are
really enhanced index funds because they
hold so many stocks in the index that by
the time you're done, you look at that
active fund for which you're paying a
fee and pay paying managers to manage
it, they're only 493 out of the 500
stocks in the S&P 500. They call
themselves a large cap fund and charge
you 1%. Effectively, you have an
enhanced index fund.
So, this is actually a graph that looks
at um Fidelity Magellan fund over time
with different managers in place. When
Peter Lynch managed the fund, it was a
small fund. You can see it was primarily
an active fund. You're picking stocks.
As the fund got bigger, and this becomes
the theme that pushes these big funds
into becoming enhanced index funds, you
can notice that the active portion drops
off. In fact, under Robert Stansky, who
managed the fund from from late '90s to
the middle of
the 2000s, you can see it became almost
entirely an index fund. The The active
portion became a very small percentage.
Harry Lang, so when you got a new
manager in, you can get the active
portion up. Whether that this is good or
bad to increase the active portion
depends on the returns. Maybe what
Stansky was doing was actually the right
thing to do.
Though then you're asking, "Why am I
paying the fees for an active fund?"
So with that said, let's go back to
enhanced index funds. Over the last 20
years, there has been this group of
funds that are that promise that they
can deliver the low cost of index funds
plus those extra returns.
The one thing to that they promise those
higher expected returns and at least in
practice, if you look at what they
delivered, it looks like you know, some
years at least they deliver more, but
some years they deliver less.
So historically, they've outperformed
the market, but with a very slight
outperformance. And here's the catch.
That outperformance comes with slightly
higher risk. So the bottom line is
enhanced index funds deliver slightly
higher returns than traditional index
funds and have slightly higher risk, are
you really better off?
In fact, you could argue that over time
enhanced index funds have not delivered
on their promise.
That, you know, that they actually
become
effectively index funds with slightly
higher cost and over time lower returns.
So here's the bottom line.
If you decide to go the passive
investing route, be proud of it. Don't
don't be defensive. It is your choice.
It is your money. And if you feel over
time you're not going to deliver the
returns from actively picking stocks, it
is the right choice for you.
Along the way, if you decide you want to
be a little active, and almost every
passive investor wants to be a little
active, you can accomplish in one of two
ways. You can try one of the enhanced
index funds, which for the most part
deliver slightly higher returns and
slightly higher risk. Or you can take a
portion of your money and invest it
actively. A little towards the end of
this class, we'll talk about these
melted philosophies where the bulk of
your money might be passively invested,
but a little portion might end up
active. But remember again, you know,
when you open up to activity, you are
opening up to the risk that that
activity will not pay off.
So, in summary, index funds have become
a much more much bigger and much more
attractive choice for many investors
because you have so many more choices
left. And their biggest promise remains
they offer those lower costs. They don't
try to beat the market.
Though a subset of them try to claim
that they can beat the market and offer
the lower cost, be be skeptical about
those promises because, you know, while
they're on paper, they may they look
good. In practice, they're much more
much more difficult to deliver.
I hope you found this session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.